alright guys ladies and gentlemen my
name is ryan right and my name is Jerry
welcome to the movie buff podcast where
we are to movie buffs that's right
people to movie buffs I'm sure you met a
couple in your life before who liked to
get buff and review movies us I'm
totally kidding we are not mark wahlberg
and Dwayne the rock Johnson we could be
cuz like you're you know you're kind of
ethnic I'm kind of on that mysterious
looking ethnic like what the [ __ ]
ethnicity are you yeah and I'm and I'm
you know the white guy yeah so if we
both got buff we could be Mark Wahlberg
and the road you know I shouldn't reveal
my ethnicity ever I I think that's gonna
be my thing that I do yeah never
revealing my ethnicity because you could
be the cliff Curtis of also acting I'll
give a hint I'm to ethnicities and yet
no one ever manages to guess one of them
correct me no one ever does so today
what we're going to be doing is we
compose our list of our top 10 favorite
movies of 2012 I'm not gonna lie to you
I'm very nervous about this I am too I'm
afraid to get judged actually okay
here's here's what I think is a good
place to come in on this um cuz he I I'd
like to describe this cuz this is the
first time I've ever put up like a top
you know 10 or 15 list of the year yeah
yeah and so my stance on it was like
this is gonna be I'm not gonna call it
like the 10 best films of the year I'm
just gonna call it in my 10 favorite
films of the year for whatever exactly
that's how I would put it to wherever
reason these films stuck with me or I
really enjoyed them and I and I like to
think that I included a lot of different
things like that's kind of what I aim
for on a top 10 list or a top whatever
number list is like I want some variety
you know different kinds of movies yeah
there's probably gonna be something
popcorn in there and there's probably
gonna be something you know Indian
obscure in there what I what I did when
I compose my list was I just found a
list of like all the movies that were
pretty much released in 2012 yeah and
whatever my heart just gravitated
towards right that's all I chose and I
made it just as simple as that and
they all happen to be a bunch of
box-office hits and you know most movie
critics I know we'll go out there and
they'll put out like some independent
film that no one's ever heard of as like
their number one favorite movie of the
year you know because there's fistik
ated well yeah I mean like I said I'm
sure hey I didn't see every movie this
year and you know there are a lot of
movies from 2012 that I'm missed that I
really want to see um but of what I did
see you know there's a there's a good
smattering and like I said you know I'm
not necessarily saying that all of these
films are the best you know quality or
the most you know world relevant films
or anything like that you know that's
not the point of my top is just like
what I enjoyed the [ __ ] out of the most
this year or appreciated really uh in a
big way oh yeah no dude absolutely and
that's exactly how I feel with my list
and just to be fair Jerry and I are not
the kind of guys I'd like to you know
rank our top 10 especially when they're
so different from one another yeah it's
like I'm not about to to compare some
kind of like I'm not gonna compare a a
comedy with like an ultimate comic book
movie you know all right it just
wouldn't be fair to do that they're so
different you know it's like one day I
might go out there and I might say oh
this comedy was all was a great film but
then a film that everybody loves I might
say you know I actually didn't like it
and people go Bree look through comedy
instead that's it's not fair to compare
the two well I've never you know my view
on any sort of rating is that it's not
fair and all too I don't I don't like
the system of rating in relation to
other movies yeah it's like her if a
comment if you give you know comedy 4
stars for whatever reason maybe it's
just a really fun comedy and it does
everything well it's got some fresh
ideas yeah and actually use a comedy
well yeah you give it four stars for
whatever reason cuz you know you think
it's for what it does it's that good
yeah yeah and then you know some other
hard-hitting drama movie you give three
and a half that everyone's gonna be like
how did you write this colony over that
yeah and
I always want to be like dude I'm not
saying that it's better than that movie
i'm just saying that this is how much i
think this movie does its own thing and
i think you know people get sort of the
wires crossed on criticism like
everything is relative and if everything
was relative them then we wouldn't then
you know ratings would be messed up
absolutely absolutely i'm excited now
okay all right so we're gonna go in
order of release date instead that's
good all right and I'm as I'm looking at
this list I'm still like what is my
number one favorite i don't think i have
a number one favorite but anyway let's
just hop right into this so uh you want
to go first time i do the honors sure
yeah well oh wait what date is your
first movie formal march the 16th okay
we'll go first because my movie comes
from january okay excellent so uh we're
not looking at each other's lips yeah no
it's a surprise it's my surprise voice
alright so yeah my first on my list is
Joe Carnahan's movie the gray starring
liam neeson and you're in guerrilla
driver you really like that movie man
i'm having that movie came out you're
talking all about it on facebook i dug
the heck out of that movie and this is
the thing this is one of those uh kind
of i love it when you see it a trailer
or something and you're like that looks
like silly fun kind of you know like you
they have the great trailer it's like
Liam Neeson punching wolves I'm in and
then I went and saw it and I was like
wow this is not that movie at all yeah
like a really it's like a
character-driven story about men versus
the elements you know the wolves are
just a looming presence and it's you
know about survival and mortality and
life and in its it stuck with me from
january throughout the entire year so
you know i found the number one
complaint about that movie was to be
wolves wouldn't do that and some people
just could not stretch their imagination
enough yeah i mean they they dress it in
the movie
and it i don't know i'm not an expert
they address it in the movie in a way
that made sense to me or not a wolf x
berg no no i haven't spent any time many
a time on a preserve you know studying
the habits for weeks on end but yeah i
don't know i mean did the explanation
they gave in the movie made sense enough
to me you know i mean i don't want to
give too much away but they're basically
saying like we're in their home this is
their home so naturally they're going to
not want us trespassing in their home
yeah so you know I get that like maybe
it's not totally realistic but it worked
for me in the movie you know what I get
what I gather from your opinion of the
movie is it's what you're saying is it
guys it's so much more than that it's
not about the wolves are just the most
advertised thing what I'm taking is what
I'm taking from what you're saying is
the wolves were the most advertised
thing because they you know sold the
entertainment value more you know
because their money in the film they're
trying to get it exciting here so that's
the number one thing I heard actually
above the wolves thing was how different
the market was wrong hair to the actual
film you know I mean it would be a hard
film to advertise but it was like when I
saw the trailers were battleship GI Joe
to uh huh like the expendables 2 it was
like all big action movies and it's just
you know it's it's not it's not them
well the writing off of Liam Neeson's
action heroes battles that he's created
at 50 years old I'm yeah wow I think I
did it but but already impressive taken
just took him in a whole new drug he's
like you people like this [ __ ] I'm gonna
keep doing more of it yeah but I I'm
just in closing on that movie I really
dug it and like I said it stuck with me
throughout the whole year so the grace
nice nice all right well first on my
list Ryan writes number one the first on
my list is 21 Jump Street release March
the 16 2012 I'm gonna Emmett can i
interject really quick we got lovely
what I have actually compiled is a is a
2012 like my favorite ten films of 2012
and i also have for honorable mentions I
guess like four films that I really
appreciated as well and 21 Jump Street
one of those for me oh so it is one of
yours how excellent it felt weird to
call it a top 14 so so I have 21 street
and that's that's my honorable one of my
honorable mention oh yeah 14 movies and
then that's your honorable mention I had
14 movies I felt compelled to speak at
least in some way about gotcha gotcha I
see well you can jump in as much as you
want on this one 21 Jump Street is
absolutely fun fantastic Johnny Depp
makes an amazing cameo yeah it was just
a it was a big surprise to me i'm not
gonna Co like off of technical
filmmaking on this one I'm going simply
from the heart here I remember watching
it and cracking up so much and being so
impressed by how different this was than
what you would usually expect especially
when that phone was announced it was
just so damn funny yeah you know like
I'm coming purely from the heart here I
love that film so much I remember just
watching jonah hill and channing tatum
up on that screen and being so impressed
with channing tatum before prior to 21
Jump Street everyone thought Channing
Tatum was a shitty actor and then when
he did 21 Jump Street everyone thought
he was fantastic I think it really
launched his career in a different
direction and he solidified his status
with Magic Mike but 21 Jump Street I
believe was the was a major catalyst to
him getting this newfound respect mm-hmm
what I thought was so cool that I didn't
even realize at the time was that what
scott pilgrim does for michael cera is
like take him give him a character that
plays exactly to his strengths and then
cook and then sort of starts to flip
that image and that's also what they do
really well in 21 Jump Street with
Channing Tatum's characters they start
him off with sort of what you think he
is this sort of like this meathead jock
guy and then the movie forces him to
become the opposite of that yes and and
that's such a smart you know neat thing
to do you know with that casting and
Jonah Hillman like seems like it was his
baby and good on him you know you really
brought together just in my opinion you
know 21 Jump Street is one of the best
comedies of the year and it's really
hard to move a
audience would laughter so consistently
I've seen it twice oh I saw it twice
last year and I had a great time each
time and I noticed more of how smart the
script was a second time so it's one of
the best movies of the year it's really
hard to move a whole audience with a
motion like that you know comedy is one
of the hardest things to execute and I
believe that if it's done well it
deserves the honorable mention and
that's why it's one of my top 10
favorites because I'm very impressed
when a comedy can get it right well this
was also one of those movies the person
I saw it with and I both turn to each
other after the movie and it's one of
those those rare movies were we get so
many sequels nowadays regardless but
this was one of those movies where right
with the movie and then we were like I
would watch another one of these right
this man yeah yeah you know definitely
props to them because it was it was a
ton of fun absolutely man absolutely so
what's next on your list my next one
comes out of april so or yours mine is
actually in March take a well take it
away I'm surprised as what's that on
your list I thought you saw something
like three times or something in the
Peters maybe maybe I overlooked
something I tried to make sure I didn't
miss anything but I have the hunger
games on my list ok I might be compelled
to throw it on my honorable mention
uh-huh my honorable mention list I mean
I I definitely liked it a lot I don't
know if I don't know if it's one of my
favorites of the of the year but um I
definitely dug it I said put either an
honorable man another Mon turbo
mentioned you got a top-five honor no I
feel so strongly that I'm like this has
to be an honorable mention but I did
quite appreciate it yeah well yeah I
love the hell out of it i remember
watching in the theaters and I wasn't
too excited to watch it i never read the
books so i'm not gonna go in comparison
to the book i'm taking the movie just as
the movie itself on its own merits and i
found it to be a really exciting film it
was always interesting throughout and i
love the use of handheld in it you know
I know you don't like and I know I
normally don't enjoy handheld because a
lot of times it seems very pretentious
it seems to me like they're trying to go
for realism it's very few movies to me
pull
off well like zero dark thirty really
pulled it off well you know when I felt
the Hunger Games pulled it off very very
well because it was this first movie you
know you get all these movies based on
books now like lord of the rings harry
potter twilight and then they come out
with a hunger games and you can't
believe i just compared Twilight to all
those votes hey my live but anyway um so
I hear about the Hunger Games you know I
kind of had my own images in mind
already based off what I heard of how it
sort of be captured or whatever but then
I ended up watching it and I've never
felt so pulled into the world before
mm-hmm they stopped its use of handheld
I think it really did that for me yeah I
mean that was was like I was sitting
there watching it and for the first
couple minutes I was like holy [ __ ] this
is really like they're really going all
in with this look and and and you really
feel like you're there there all the
time it's you it's a bleak mood and a
really great acting especially from
Jennifer Lawrence really sells it yeah
Kravitz bro Lenny is all about the
crabbits in that baby man no yes I mean
she's great and there's an in supporting
cast it's pg-13 but there's violence in
it that I was kind of shocked to see in
a pg-13 movie we never seen a bunch of
teenagers just murdering the [ __ ] out of
each other but if yeah those that was
interesting thing is it is it you know
cuz it's one of those young adult books
and that's an easy category to roll your
eyes at nowadays but you know like i
said i was like wow this is some heavy
stuff for you know a young adult book
you know or an adaptation of a young
adult book and you know I dougie it's a
raw raw raw movie you know it's it's
it's it doesn't hold back and i love
that for a film that's based off a book
that mainly you know children teenagers
gravitate towards it's awesome to see
how raw film like that was and did it
through pg-13 status as well it's it's a
very ambitious film yeah very very
ambitious movie it's amazing what the
NPA will let you get away with when you
just don't let people
yes exactly but there are some moments
where like people get their face is
smashed into giant metal boxes when
they're in the corner is stabbing them
yeah I kind of each other man like that
like the stung or bodies and stuff like
that I'm like this is kind of intense
mmm yeah a very authentic acting
throughout to yeah yeah very impressed
with that phone but anyway so um I have
a april one as well next on my list I do
too you have an april one as well are we
gonna overlap mine came out on for 11
for 11 no is it okay we're gonna do a
one two three on this one okay all right
ok ready 1 2 2 3 the avengers yes the
same movie it's the same movie marbles
marvel's the avengers marvel Ziva I
think it's the only movie that came out
that day The Avengers is a [ __ ]
awesome movie probably the most awesome
film this year like if there was one
more to describe awesome i would think
marvel's the avengers does it with being
awesome it is no it's jawsome its jaw
some very go that's great you know it's
got a wonderful [ __ ] script an
amazing scream rabbi I mean you could
really tell that he gets and loves those
characters yeah that's what I mean it's
it's surprisingly character driven every
characters acknowledged I remember that
was like the biggest thing I was
concerned about when I heard about the
Avengers was yeah how are they gonna
possibly pull this off how are they
gonna make everyone feel like they all
got their do you know yet he does it
superbly you know to find out he not
only directed it but also wrote it
that's fantastic information it's like
whoa please do all of the Avengers
movies don't stop and not only that too
is she's not just great at writing
characters he's great at capturing
action as well there was one shot that
everyone talked about that even people i
know that don't know how to describe you
know film technical stuff people still
talked about this moment where it's
tracking everyone in the finale and in
one single shot and just wow
every one of the Avengers kicking ass in
one shot together as a team [ __ ] yeah
one fat [ __ ] smile was on my face
yeah I was watching that it was amazing
man you just couldn't believe how cool
of a film it was awesome awesome and at
the same time to it doesn't sacrifice
what you want which is just a badass
superhero film LLC as the thing is like
oh all my best lines end up coming from
other people but like there there were
two points made about this movie that
thought we're especially poignant is
like Neil Patrick Harris I think said
that like what's so great about dress
we'd new new vendors is that the action
scenes will be thrilling but the talking
scenes will be just as thrilling as the
acne up and he totally accomplished that
man yeah totally and also like just the
way he somebody else pointed me just the
way he is able to deconstruct a
character whilst also completely being
true to that character is is amazing
just just all the character called
especially with like everyone was
worried about Hulk it seems like and man
Bruce Banner I can see why there'd be a
lot of concern around the Hulk you know
that was like the one film that just
didn't seem to truly get it right yeah
the only attempts that no one ever quite
nailed it was like perfectly nailed it
yeah exactly you know I really like the
edward norton one but at the same time I
was like I don't really see a franchise
coming from this yeah it's like mark you
know it was another one's choice of
words like Mark Ruffalo yeah i thought i
was like Mark Ruffalo yeah um dude Mark
Ruffalo was the best hope they've ever
had and i hope i hope they do a movie
with him i really do i know they said i
don't have one of the pipeline but i
really hope they do and like this is the
most importantly i think it live up to a
type total i mean that that third act
alone that that big finale battle was uh
hmm ah like it's the perfect like it is
all the ultimate nerdgasm of awesome
spectacular and they did something I did
not expect them to do which is what i
wanted and an end and thought how cool
it would be to see but i didn't expect
them to do is with a they managed to
make the carrier
The Avengers and at times fight each
other yeah and see the powers go
toe-to-toe against one not just work
together but go against each other well
yeah cuz they yes that has to learn to
be it oh it's like out of a video game
you want that well now see that was his
from all the earliest interviews like
that was the big thing that I guess drew
Joss Whedon to this was he said like
this is a these are the Avengers is a
bunch of people who have no business
being in the same room together being in
the same room together and that's what
I'm gonna work with and like that's
that's awesome because not only does it
make for great story but also and it's
just awesome to nerd out over iron man
fighting Captain America fighting Thor
fighting all like all those all those
different hero vs. hero matchups is just
like oh it's just so cool to see them
all on the same screen together cuz
that's that that's that nerd debate you
know it's like you sit around with your
buddies me like who would win in a fight
you know like Iron Man or mayhap you
knows so wow it's red it's so rad what
you got next on the dates I have a june
i have a new i have an april again oh
yeah man April's again yeah I have a
feeling I know what this one is I have a
feeling to my date might be wrong
because I know these movies didn't come
out Oh a never mind if you said your day
might be wrong I really long is it since
I think you would know the release date
on the movie i'm thinking of like right
off the top of your head know why I
should but now well I'm not gonna say
the dangers yet because i think i might
have it wrong but Kevin Lewis oh it is
Kevin avoid yeah yeah cabin in the woods
oh my there's what is up that's what i
was thinking yeah yeah well what do you
have a date on that no i don't have a
date on that cuz this is the 13th and i
have a feeling that might be wrong so um
but anyway cabin in the woods oh my god
i'm like i am a huge horror fan for
those who don't know mm-hmm and you know
i can't say much about it because it's
one of those movies that's precious
because there's twists and turns
everywhere and there are so many things
that are GSS it's a 13th yeah okay well
good month for jobs we'd
um but so I just got the information had
an interrupt you with this important
information is what is able day okay cuz
that's the day i have here i guess i
just don't know but um yeah it's drew
goddard who um dude directed no matt
reeves it The Drew Goddard who wrote
cloverfield and who's done a bunch of
buffy and stuff with Joss Whedon and
Joss Whedon mom so you know it's it's
from a very smart team of writers and
it's it it's like take what scream did
for movies mm-hmm and then multiply that
times like 20 nice cuz it's like it
deconstructs the genre while mixing it
with stuff while also writing a love
letter to it they're just it's one of
those movies where every time you're
like oh that would be cool but it's
probably not gonna happen mm-hmm then it
[ __ ] ass yeah like it's constantly
one upping the experience and it's oh I
can't say enough about it is definitely
my favorite films the year aside
multiple times I heard it was also like
funny at the same time to like it
manages to also be a really funny film
it's really funny it's really witty it's
it's really smartly written and I hidden
but I hear they have like all these
elements kind of working together at
once yeah you know that's all right ton
it's it's kind of a mash-up it's kind of
a puzzle box of genres and themes but it
all it's so good and then once you're
done with it it sort of affects how you
look at other movies mhm so like that
movie as cliche as this term is that
movie is a game changer thank you in a
way and it's up you know if you're a
horror fan if even if you're not a
horror fan you know all you gotta know
is the five teenagers going to a cabin
in the woods set up and you and you will
appreciate it and the cast is great you
know in Chris Hemsworth you know that's
partly how he got the role of Thor was
through Joss Whedon working on cabin in
the woods with him and that he
recommended him to Kenneth Branagh so
incredibly well-written well directed
and just weeding to the second unit
it was like a total team so Kevin woods
man all the way that's great so yeah
cabin in the woods man okay okay what's
your next release date um my next
release is June I don't have a specific
day on it because it's a it's a little
bit of an odd of an obscurity but huh
well I don't think this movies on your
list so maybe I should take a scoffer
it's the type of June want to take it
away yeah you know what I talked a lot
about Kevin you you take it away on this
one well I'm sure you'll be fine with
this movie because you saw it it's uh
Ted okay that was June really yeah jun
29th oh yeah all right and I really dug
this film you know it's a fantastic film
in my opinion it's you know a lot of
people complained about like oh it's
just senator like romance bromance sorry
but that's what I like about Seth
MacFarlane style he tends to take simple
movies but make them a little bit
outrageous yeah well and I mean even so
like it's an outrageous plot because
it's not it's it's a talking teddy bear
it's not yeah yeah I mean even if it's
even if it is you know a romantic comedy
romance story like it's really
well-executed even just in the
construction yeah yeah it's you know
it's if the thing about Ted that I found
the most interesting is how believable
Ted was cuz he's a talking teddy bear
and yet the effects that on Ted are not
distracting you just solely by its it's
a good performance by Seth MacFarlane it
was done through motion captured and
it's sir yeah it was yeah he's a pretty
big guy yeah he did the performance and
he's fantastic in it and I thought I
should have got a more credit because he
blends well into the world and that's a
great job at Seth mcFarland of creating
this story and I thought it was kind of
underrated in that aspect what I think
all the like all the you know the plot
is tech is one thing I always hard on
with this movie that I think it got so
right is that there's never a moment
where I was like you could have just had
a two-minute conversation and solved all
these problems like that's a
fall for a lot of these kinds of movies
and it completely avoided that for me so
you know I just got to give it total
credit for being well constructed like
it's not in my top but I definitely
appreciate it I I thought it had lifted
my spirits I remember before and i'll
get really honest about it like I
remember before I actually watched the
film I was actually a really like down
mood I really wasn't feeling good that
day like I was pretty sad and I went to
go watch the film and I didn't think
anything could really lift up my spirits
but that film had all these certain
elements of joy but crudeness and a lot
of different like a lot of sympathy a
lot of heart yet it managed to still be
like have a lot of profanity yeah it was
able to do so much in so many different
levels of humor that I find funny and it
pulled each element off so well see
maybe why i don't i don't have it higher
is because for me the only place where
it you know sort of faltered was was the
comedy and just in the sense that i just
didn't laugh as much as everybody else
did mm-hmm you know so it's it's not
even like I don't think it's funny it's
just that was I didn't find it like oh
my god I was laughing every minute but
that's I guess that might be a
contributing factor so I don't like love
it enough to put it on the list well
yeah that's mean that's fair that's just
how you felt towards the movie I mean
there's nothing wrong with that like it
would be have we stupid of me to try to
convince you over how would you not find
this funny what's wrong with your
emotions John I mean what's wrong how
could you not find this funny what's
wrong with your emotions Jerry mmm you
know what I mean ya know but I get you
on that like I it's not from from this
year but like horrible bosses did that
to me ya see horrible bosses is it on my
list it was not from 2012 anyway but I
was like I was having a crappy crappy
awful day when I oak and then we were
just like let's go see a comedy horrible
bosses out and like it turned me around
so like I can totally see that with 10
for you yeah really lifted my spirits
are reminding me of that buddy you know
relationship yeah for sure that I hope
we have
hmm yeah Peter laughs anyway that's why
I love teddy and plus it just kept me
laughing the whole time that's like the
most main important part for me it did
keep me laughing the whole time and
there were times where I just cracked up
so hard and I would reflect back on
those jokes and yeah it definitely have
lifted my spirits anyway what's next on
your list next on my list is um I'm
counting it as June because I guess
that's when a debut this year I saw this
at the I saw this in a in a sort of
limited run it's a it's quite an
obscurity and it's a very divisive film
but it is a movie called beyond the
black rainbow beyond the black rainbow
Wow so tell me about this felt this is a
it's a movie by a guy named panos
cosmatos whose dad is pretty big in
Hollywood like history on but it's this
strange kind of science fictiony film
that like takes place in the 80s but it
has these sort of 60s 70s vibes to it
yeah it's a really kind of it's like
it's not a traditional narrative story
like there isn't narrative but it's it's
more this like fever dream of imagery
and you know metaphors and it's just a
full-on oral you know visual experience
and it's just so overwhelming in terms
of the vision like it you're the first
time you watch it you're not even quite
sure what you saw completely but okay
it's stuck with me man like just the the
images and the music and the visit a
horror film mmm sort it has it has
horror ish element is certainly
unsettling in a lot of places so it's
kind of sci fi [ __ ] I wouldn't go out
and say like it's it's straight up [ __ ]
but it certainly sounds like a certainly
as some horror to it sounds like space
odyssey a little bit you know it's like
if you took the end like the last like
with the light tunnel on the and the
room where it's the baby and then he's
an old man if you took that sequence and
made it into a movie
that's that's a you would at least be
kind of prepared for what you're about
to walk into mm-hmm it's a it's a slow
burn flick it's very deliberately paced
so some folks might not have the
patience for it but definitely sounds
like space odyssey yeah but on oh it's
it's a it's a strongly crafted flick
it's very strange and like I said it's
also very divisive because some people
put it on their top some people put it
on their bottom lists as in it on both
places equally for me it's on my top um
that experience hasn't left me yet you
know I still think about it a lot that's
great I'm glad that I'm glad that a
movie can do that man you know it's
always great to hear about a movie that
can actually really affect someone like
that um anyway so let's move on and
let's move on my next movies of July
release so is mine I have a feeling
we're on the same movie we've been to
the room so to speak I think we've
talked about this privy an awful lot
yeah we have I mean I already have my
own review up later and we have a
podcast coming up for it I think is it
the same one that we're talking about i
haven't pretty sure and it's and it's
the other side of a coin we got this
year which is interesting so you want to
go ahead and i do the honors yes it is
the dark knight rises again with your
help oh oh of course I can't channel my
bane impression now yeah there's always
there when you're doing fun is never
there what he did ya know you have the
dark knight rises man whoo ya know like
I said this is a for me this is like the
other side of a coin because you have
the Avengers which is like a perfectly
executed fun comic book movie and then
the other side you have the Dark Knight
Rises which is a really well executed
much more realistic yet darker more
realistic more serious in a way comic
book movie and I'm so glad that those
two movies can come out
insane year uh-huh yeah absolutely ain't
on a lot of people kept comparing it to
the [ __ ] dark night but it is like
I'm not saying that like the dark knight
is is my favorite one of the trilogy it
is it absolutely is but that doesn't
make the dark knight rises a bad movie
it just because the predecessor is not
as good does not make it a bad movie I
have to really emphasize that because I
think people were not taking this film
on its own merits like they should have
well yeah cuz like a I always kind of
felt like you have to see this movie
twice regardless because the first time
is sort of a catharsis because it's like
yeah you remember right I saw with you
and I didn't even like it the first time
I saw it well yeah is like Batman Begins
was unexpected everyone was like Paul
this that's a cool flick I didn't expect
this from these people i don't really
know and then the dark matter The Dark
Knight came out it was like oh my god
this is all those when's the next one
and so like there was so much hype and
expectation going into the dark knight
rises that I I became very weary because
it's like I don't think anyone at least
on the first time can watch this movie
and just watch it no no there's so much
an anticipatory anxiety you know like
yeah it beyond immaculate people are
gonna nitpick the [ __ ] out of it and
that's it seems that seems to happen a
lot and I think you just want to absorb
the information so much because of all
the anticipation that one has that you
can't just sit back and relax and soak
it in the first time you watch it it
does take a second viewing because it
does take a little bit of readjusting
because it is a it is captured
differently than the dark night it's
captured differently than Batman Begins
yeah they're all they're all three all
three are very different and that's what
makes it up an awesome [ __ ] trilogy
that's why that picture I think it's on
our pockets actually that picture where
they spliced the three images to make
the bat symbol it's like one's the fire
one's the ice one's the metal and that's
a really good sort of image sympa like a
symbolic image of of how that trilogy is
because each one has a different vibe
and a different you know set of
trappings but they're all you know one
fork yeah and everything about it at the
end of the day despite whatever minor
flaws there are and some that might even
if you consider some sea
they're to be big flaws I don't even
care if you liked everything about it
but you can't get over the [ __ ] thing
with you know Batman and how we survived
the bomb like if fuller there's still oh
yeah I think everyone's ready so how bad
man survived the bomb right m still
that's like that's like the last like
ten minutes of the film you're talking
about right now there's still two hours
and twenty other minutes so that you
could be observing as well it's not
there's so much greatness in it that it
outshines the bad at the end of the day
if you have to make a list of pros and
cons the pros outweigh the cons yeah
well I also feel like you know this is a
movie where there's so much stuff you
know I mean there are so many things to
have it and there's so much technical
stuff there's just too much to me to
completely write it off you know cuz I
mean everybody likes to get you know the
hyperbole going and really go you know
when people are let down they get really
exaggerated but it's there's too much
stuff in this movie to write it off as a
bad movie yeah what's sad to me is how
we've encountered so many haters that
it's shaped our opinion when we express
it into defending the [ __ ] movie all
the time like it's so automatic because
guys man it is a it's just truly a
fantastic film it really is I mean it
you know I really do I saw it multiple
times and the more you watch it doesn't
it get better each time it gets better
you catch more things it feels more
smooth and I mean that's another thing i
didn't get is everyone you know who
freaked out about it wouldn't launch it
again and i know that most of those
people watch the dark knight like 18
times so I'm like if you love this this
trilogy or these the tip the first to as
much as you say you do and you love
Nolan's vision as much as you say you
did a lot of people didn't seem willing
to revisit the dark knight rises and I'm
like if you love it so much and you keep
saying it why don't you want to maybe
like why wouldn't you want it to be
better like at the end of the day most
people like it so if you don't like it
why don't you go revisit it
find out why everyone else does and I'm
in and again I'm not saying that
everyone has to like it i just it like i
said it just feels like a movie that a
lot of people because of all the hype
and chaos a lot of people are you know
knocking and nitpicking because of
things beyond just the experience of
watching yeah and you know what you know
we don't credit enough about that movie
the [ __ ] score yeah I'm telling you
guys if you guys buy the soundtrack and
just drive around in the car listening
to it it's the most awesome experience
in the world it's a fantastic soundtrack
it gets your mind moving it gets your
heart moving and especially watching it
on you know in the theaters or maybe
just on a loud television hmm it's it's
a fantastic it's a fantastic score well
yeah that's one of those movies that's
not a horror movie but I sort of view as
one because there's a lot of unsettling
stuff in that movie you know and I mean
like I said you don't have to love it
you know whatever it's fine if you don't
like it and you really like it for a
legitimate reason that that's fine but
for me you know it affected me it
impacted me I dug the heck out of it
Baines awesome at the other day hey
how's the acting it's all good how's the
directing you know for the most part
it's all good how's the writing for the
most part it's all good every everything
is good and it does a lot it is it
original yes they do a lot of things
you've never seen done before in a movie
and the story goes places you haven't
seen you know ever in a movie yeah at
the end of the day that provides you
with a lot of things that are very
unique it's an ambitious movie and it's
an to think somebody point out to me
it's like one of the one of the few
times you've ever seen the villain win
halfway through the yeah yeah like and
you just watch everything change you
watched like the genre changes like an
apocalypse movie all of a sudden yeah
it's I mean there's there's some really
scary stuff there at least to me it's
like you know it's about terrorism and
and you know just this there's some
really bleak symbolism and really bleak
you know just things that happen you
know and you know what you know what's
great about it to me is when Batman
Begins came out everyone was so ripped
like raving about Batman and
Dark Knight came out everyone was raving
about the Joker you know and in this one
the dark knight rises brings you back to
i'm not saying like hey it's wrong i
love the joker I mean I the Joker's like
one of my favorite performances of all
time people of Heath Ledger's but with
the dark knight rises you know it's like
it brings you back to like oh yeah
that's why Batman so awesome you know it
brings it full circle and like I mean we
could talk for hours and we have about
you know the dynamics of each but you
know yeah yeah definitely we should move
on yeah I could say yeah we should
definitely move all it's your net yeah
because we're gonna have a whole another
Dark Knight haters podcast next on my
list is a September release oh I've got
an August Oh what's your August my
August is august seventeenth and that
would be ParaNorman ParaNorman actually
did not bother to check that movie help
well [ __ ] you it just didn't look
appealing to me at the time but but tell
me what is okay what what's what's uh
Tommy the appeal please parallel I mean
again I'm a big heard a lot of great
things I'm gonna by the way yeah yeah
for sure I mean for me again I'm a big
horror fan but my love for prior army
goes beyond that it's like um I went to
see it and it's really cool if you're a
[ __ ] face there's a lot of those
trappings and it's very macabre and
creepy it's not a it's a movie that kids
can see but it's not a kids movie
doesn't pander to kids um you know and
it's it's like the perfect introduction
to or if you have a child and also i
just like i like the story I really
identified with Norman the character
just you know cuz you know I think
everyone's felt that way in a sense and
i really liked all the characters i
really like for the story went and I
gotta say like the the underlying
message of the movie really kind of blew
me away because I'm like this is not
what I'm used to seeing in you know uh
you know I'm not gonna call the kids
movie but you know like a family movie
that you know you could take your family
to an animated film it's not the type of
message you're used to seeing I mean yo
cuz be yourself and you know
can achieve anything our great messages
but this message was so different and so
true to me and so telling that you know
I just fell in love with this movie you
know I only saw TV spots for it and one
of the things I heard the most about was
how amazing the animation actually is
yeah I mean I don't know how the
processes were but the claymation I mean
the design is why everything has i will
give you i heard it's pretty frightening
yeah it was yeah no it's certainly do
see coraline yes i did cuz Coraline is
kind of upsetting to and and this Vybez
is um it's got a different vibe from
Coraline but you know you'll know the
sort of you know kind of what you're
getting into if you know Coraline okay
excellent but um yeah the animation is
great i mean the design of the
characters it's like everything is
slightly asymmetrical so everyone has a
really unique you know kind of real look
almost yeah yeah her it's kind of like a
cross between like um I heard one person
put it this way is rook it's kind of
like a cross between old school and uh
like cutting edge at the same time yeah
I mean if it was Richard Roeper actually
who said that yeah no I mean the
animations great you know like the
claymation the design of all the
characters and I don't know um all the
processes they used but it all blends
together really well you like if they
use cg at all it all works together and
it's really cohesive I love you know the
voice talent was all great and you know
and if you're a horror fan you know
there are a lot of little nods and
homages and little things so I just
really dug it on every level absolutely
man that sounds great fantastic all
right my next release is the September
release yes mine is too late September
or early sitn late-september
late-september yeah I mean I think we
have the same think we're on the same
baby hey all right ready 123 lubar yeah
yeah yeah that's the [ __ ] movie right
there oh that's a contender for number
one for me for sure if I had to rank i
would say looper is close to the top if
it's not the time yes because it's it's
a it's a brave brave film and it
you need yeah [ __ ] what every everything
about that movie is crafted yes you know
it's like ah like there was there is
such a strong vision behind that movie
like ryan Johnson knocked that one out
of the park really mm-hmm oh it's great
to see an awesome sci-fi film again you
know I I love science fiction when it's
pulled off beautifully you know
Terminator 2 is one of my favorite films
of all time just because it's sci-fi
pulled off brilliantly matrix does it
awesome and the looper not the looper
looper does it great as well well yeah
and it's got its got a great world and a
great you know just an aura and and what
I like about it partly is that it's a
time travel movie that doesn't get
caught up in being all about time travel
mechanics and how cool the geology is
it's it's a human story it's a story
about people and it just so happens the
time travel is involved do you know it's
and it's great to see Bruce Willis in a
movie where it's an it's an action movie
he's not just playing he's playing an
old guy again it's great to see Bruce
Willis in an action movie where he's
doing some real acting again and Joseph
gordon-levitt is superb absolutely
superb Emily Blunt comes from late into
the phone but she's great either there
are some moments where I remember
watching that movie and going whoa yeah
seriously no just a lot of a lot of
different mixed emotions it takes you on
one hell of an adventure that's totally
that's unique complex yet simple to
follow its manages to get every point
across and you can keep up with the
whole journey and it's unbelievably
unique at the same time yeah totally and
all the great action to just great
action overall totally and like every
every bit of casting is great you know
noah segan is great Paul Dano is great
Jeff Daniels is great even even
characters only show up for like a
couple months like Garret Dillahunt I
was like really into and you gotta give
a shout-out to that kid cuz that deaf
kids it crazy as it actually
and what's most impressive it's still
character-driven mayor yeah I know
that's part of why I liked it so much is
because like I said it's a time travel
movie that's not all about look at how
cool our time travel is yeah it's about
characters yeah people oh oh no Jerry
anest up there's a July release actually
that I have again I guess we're gonna
have to go back and close our loop Oh
perfect oh great great was meant to be a
he was meant to be so you could pull
that off yeah right fantastic we're
gonna have to go every time my next
flick is so I had to drink something my
next flick is the amazing spider-man
okay young I was impressed you know I
was very much against this film and I
came out of that movie liking it more
than two of the installments of the
prior trilogy I like it more than the
original spider-man and I liked it more
than spider-man 3 Wow so I was bold pray
I was very much impressed with andrew
garfield's performance the action to me
was freakin awesome and it was very much
character driven they managed to make it
a dark tale and to make it a much more
grounded and realistic it made it a much
more believable world rather than a
fantasy world yeah and I was really
impressed by how they did that some
people still find it to be unnecessary
me on the other hand I found it to be
home one hell of a refreshing take yeah
man I dug it i mean like i said it's you
know it's not on my top list but i
definitely enjoyed it with you i enjoyed
it too and I you know I was super
against the idea but when I went in you
know I've dug the flick so mm-hmm it's a
worthy injury it's not it's not my list
personally but it is worthy injury to
hear more about our opinion on the
amazing spider-man check out our review
at real reasons to see com we do have a
review and I better will be in this
video right here so click that link
alright what's next what's your next
date
I have a October release I do as well
but I'm not sure I you know what I am
I'm positive we don't have a movie okay
what's your movie this man's late
October mine's October 12 miles s number
26 all right well I'm gonna take this
one Ryan okay next on my list sinister
go sinister yes ugly that was um you
know that's that's a one from bloom
house and I'm continually impressed with
what they do I haven't seen paranormal
activity 4 but um yeah sinister man i
haven't been chilled in a while like
like there's a lot of different things
you can take out of a horror movie and
this one was was [ __ ] like this movie
chilled me to the bone like it's it's a
slow burn it takes its time but it is
sinister is the perfect title for
because there are a lot of really
unsettling unnerving images here has a
lot of good twists as well mmhmm yeah
and I mean the performance the other
thing is like I always harp on this
about horror movies because people ask
me you like why do you love blood and
killing I'm like it's it's not just that
it's like the same things that make a
movie good apply and part of just what
adds to why I love this movie is you
know you've got a well-conceived script
it's well directed and you have
characters who are characters like you
have this family you know Ethan Hawke
and Julie Rylands like they together you
really believe their relationship and
there are scenes were there just arguing
because of like the psychological
effects of this situation where you're
just like the drama takes over you're
like holy [ __ ] it's it's just like
watching your parents fight like it if
the performances are great the visual
style is really cool the lighting is
really cool because it's very minimal
light oh nice and it's just unsettling
and creepy and you know a nice you know
spooky twist on a haunted house through
like it does a lot of mainstay things
really well and it does some new things
too and it was a good time I really dug
it so uh shoutout to uh to a see Robert
cargo massive worm is a good job on that
script shadow scott derrickson too good
director and co-writer good supporting
cast get everything man i recommend it
what's yours what's your october i would
have to say my next one is came out a
few days before Halloween 1026 and that
is Cloud Atlas hibbity and how cloud
atlas cloud app I missed Cloud Atlas and
I am a huge jackass yeah you are for
missing that movie it's one heck of an
ambitious film if there is a if there is
a word to describe the most ambitious
movie I saw this year I mean of last
year if there was one movie to describe
the word ambitious film of 2012 to me it
would be cloud atlas oh yeah never have
I seen a film like that before and I
don't think many other people have
either it's told very different and
honestly I remember watching it the
first time it's like almost a three hour
film I don't even know if it's three
hours or not but everything is here's
three yeah no one can contain their
information any morning on Jump Street
was three hours Ted was three hours no
it's pretty close to three hours it's
like two hours and 45 minutes something
like that but its enemy anyway uh that's
one thing I saw the trailer i was like i
don't know i don't understand anything i
just saw i want to see it i know it will
be very well yeah so you can jump across
all these different times and places and
have people play multiple characters if
you're only gonna be a 90-minute movie
at first it's very distracting a watch
like the first hour and a half I was
getting anxiety watching this whole it
was just so is like oh my god it's I
still that I didn't can't get pulled
into it and uh you know I was with my
friend too and I have we both just could
not get pulled into this film down and
like the last hour and a half became
this amazing film out of nowhere once
you learn how to settle in it's one of
those films that's definitely better the
second time you watch it yeah i mean
sure there won't be some excitement
that's the same but it's one of those
okay it's one of those films it's better
the second time you watch it because and
then you can finally absorb the whole
film it does a lot of very unique things
things of just having actors play all
these different roles in different time
periods and then having different time
period stories being told and each one
feeling like a different genre they
managed to pull off six different films
and put it into one they did it they
accomplished their goal you can't ignore
the the the overall scope yes can see
that's something that I kind of I could
kind of gleam like from the vibe was
like I have a feeling that this will be
a challenging experience the first time
and then once you can revisit it with
you know some familiarity and
preparation for what's coming mmm you
know I can see how you would definitely
want to watch that movie twice and when
I get a hold of it I will watch it boy
all right next date next date I have a
have a November release I do as well I
have early to violate November so take
it away my friend it's skyfall skyfall
skyfall yes we have a review of it real
reasons to see but sure I'll give a
little click here look give you a little
recap we need traffic actually my film
is skyfall skyfall yup I was really
excited when I heard Sam Mendes was
directing this because I Russian airy
road man yeah I'm never gonna tell Magan
engine or not and so I I saw Road to
Perdition when I was young and the older
I get the better it gets sorry i
completely forgot that this movie as a
hell of a move yet is that is it's one
of my favorite movies of all time and
Skyfall is directed by him and it's
pulled off exceptionally well it's one
of the best Bond movies when you can say
that so late into a friend
it's hey you can say wow it's one of the
best Bond movies well here's the thing
about franchises those that franchises
like that are long have very random ups
and downs cuz like you know I'm a big
soft and like randomly saw six is really
good you feel like and like Jason six is
my favourite jason movies like you know
I can see I can see how late installment
is one of the best it's the most
character-driven Skyfall I've ever seen
I mean that's what scared of Skyfall
franchise one clearly says it's the most
kick it's the most character-driven Bond
film I've ever seen because you're going
from multiple characters a no casino
royale did a character-driven type of
bond film but this one really you get to
know everyone so well they all drive the
story it's an amazing accomplishment I
had a great time watching it one of the
best villains of the bond series I've
ever seen yeah I've you ever Ardennes
yeah this is another one like I said you
know this is another one where I really
dug it it didn't make my top list but
you know I'm I share a lot of your
sentiments on it and I've hung over damn
man easily these such a delicious
villain it's just one of the best it's
the best it's just the best blend of old
bond a new bond well yeah because you
know it's like you got this one
statement deal like they're kind of
redefining it and then I feel like
quantum of solace is like they tried to
go off in a direction and it was also my
wrath of the problems and it ultimately
didn't work out and then they came back
to Skyfall made it super personal and
found a nice bounce I'm old and new and
you know there's a huge undertone of
that so I'm I'm down it's good stuff
okay okay so what's your November
release might have ever release is gonna
raise some eyebrows it's a November 30th
and I can already hear the people going
you put that on your favorite movies of
2012 Liz but you know what I don't care
my my November movie November 30th is
the collection ooh I and I'm putting
this on here for me I don't care i'm
putting
for me I'm a big fan of the collector
and this movie um this movie is it's
like think of what aliens is to alien
the collection is to the collector and I
just had a blast with it you know I like
the characters I like the style you know
they it was only as long as it needed to
be is only really missing one thing to
make it you know just you know it was
only missing one thing that would have
made you know for me not perfection in
the sense of life this is the greatest
movie but you know it's like it was only
missing one thing and you know what the
rest of it was was so much fun and you
know creative it's like they said you
know building a better mousetrap and I
thought they did that and you know I
love Josh Stewart in the role at emma
fitzpatrick is great the the female lead
the collector is creepy you know i like
the way they changed it up and I you
know we get a lot of franchises now but
i would definitely watch another
collector movie i had a blast and when i
left couldn't wait to see it again i
will say this way i heard about that
movie was how you know torture porn
films really don't get recommended that
that high i know but that's like what at
the end of the day that's what
everyone's been categorized and hit him
and if we're a torture porn film it was
rated rather high or a murder torture
porn film you know yeah yeah but the
collection of the collector the
collection yeah because they both are
and I mean yeah yeah no it's telling its
I have a theory of sort of like rotten
tomatoes a relativity for for horror
movies it's like if it's like a 40 it's
probably all right because you got to
multiply the scores by two so you know
people seem to dig the collection you
know and appreciate it and you know I'm
happy good cast it's you know it's
pretty smartly done and and they really
did a good job with their female lead
the way they handled it's a good
character she was a great actress I'm so
Donna and I love Josh Stewart his organs
so collection good times you need good
stuff what's next on your date my got
one more it's uh I think I know
mine's a Christmas movie magic risotto
we did all right all right you a
countdown 3 2 1 Django Unchained yes sir
Chris could not leave that off this
might be number one on my list actually
i Reichel yeah it's definitely in my top
three favorites django and chain is the
reason movies are made for sure for sure
you know it's it's everything it's
stylish it's unique its bold its violent
is its violent it's a violent film hmm i
will say that yeah it's a violent from
the violence the violence escalates into
more violent as the film progresses well
yeah it's like you have this one side of
the violence that this really bloody
exaggerated you know spaghetti western
style and then you also on the flip side
have these scenes of you know these
horrible things happening to slaves and
stuff there's there's a scene involving
dogs and you know some of the violence
is over the top and extreme and some of
it is is actually hard to watch and on
you know unsettling so there's a heads
it's not for the faint of heart and he
really knows how to put his characters
in situations where you're like [ __ ]
that are gonna they're gonna die yeah
you know how to make you got a he knows
how to get you to that point where you
wonder how he knows how to get you to
that point where you wonder how like
whoa what are our heroes gonna do to to
get out of this is there any way to
leave this relatively a locket a lot of
different forms of tension going on to
through their violence just tension
through the scenes of dialogue man it's
great fantastic fantastic film pure
Tarantino Tarantino unlimited Tarantino
to the extreme now unlimited sounds
better and also I mean you gotta
DiCaprio Christoph Waltz Jamie Foxx like
Sam Jackson all everyone is great i
forgot about actors and it was just
these characters and like oh and i mean
i gotta say this was also one of my
favorite experiences of the year
because I got to see it at the New
Beverly which you know is kind of
tarantino's theater and you put together
all experience for that and it's all
it's the way to see that movie was it
was completely immersive and fun so ah
Django man Django well ladies and
gentlemen oh wait wait just before we go
I just want to mention a couple movies
really quick couple honorable mentions
that I just I just want to assure milege
um I'm uh I'm a fan of Darren Ballard's
work i'm a big repo genetic opera fan so
i got a shout out to the devil's
carnival they did it towards it's kind
of a short film but it's another sort of
musical outing and they made a whole
experience out of it with you know
basically something you could never get
just watching a DVD and it was it was
really cool to see so shout out the
devil's carnival shout out to safety not
guaranteed which was a movie I really
enjoyed by the dude with the duplass
brothers and a few other people it's a
little indie sort of quirky film but you
know really wonderful movie really
enjoyed that and beasts of the southern
wild which was a I went in blind that's
that's a that's a hell of an experience
it's a lot of emotions so uh yeah so
Devil's Carnival safety not guaranteed
beasts of the southern wild and as I
also mentioned for 21 Jump Street those
definitely get an honorable mention
really dug those flicks do well
excellent excellent i'm glad you had
more movies to enjoy this year than just
those ten that we talked about I'm sorry
I just felt I felt super compelled
because those were going to be sorry you
know it's not worth it already well
that's it today for our top 10 favorite
movies of 2012 I love how you know this
one was really winged today I like we
were like you want to just talk about
our top 10 favorite movies like you know
we didn't even have a list really
prepared and then as we found our list
it was great to revisit it through
talking about it yeah now it's a go
through every film and be like wow
that's right I remember that experience
you know that was to sit here be like is
it really does have that affected like
oh no I want to watch that right yeah
each day each time we talked about it I
really wanted to watch each one of those
move
so I had great time talking about it I
hope you guys enjoy talking with us yeah
thank you guys if you're if you're still
here thank you so much and if you're
talking you shouldn't be just be
listening as Noah podcaster or for ya
unless you want to pause it and talk
about what you thought of our opinion
yes that is an exception yeah but if
you're talking while you're listening
then you're not listening so yeah so
listen [ __ ] yeah we're telling people
to listen no the podcast is over listen
to the sounds of silence is this podcast
comes dinner but uh yeah thank you much
and uh till next time i'm ryan right i'm
gerry this has been then the movie vava
podcast of all the things we said
together that was not one way yeah
alright goodnight goodnight oh good
afternoon